and now tristan mckenzie he will be our
northeast ohio four dealers starting
pitcher for today joe hey otani in the
lead off spot and has been spectacular
swag and a miss he's down swinging for
out number one
swag and a miss how's that for an
opening act strikes out a pair
angels go in order and reed deadmaurs as
mark pointed out all four of his starts
against postseason teams from last year
and he still goes into each one of these
outings with a lot of confidence
there's a base hit to right field and
the mid rosario
just keeps on hitting
yeah he's scorching in the month of
august he is on fire once he got about
29 hits or so
ramirez bangs one to left and that is
deep and that is off the wall
upton
look at rosario flying around third and
he is out at the plate they got him
stassi with the tag
terrific relay upton started it when he
played it off the wall and it's a double
for ramirez but it doesn't score the run
ramirez breaks for third
runners over there and a double steal
for the indians and he just passed
richard eugene manning on the all-time
stolen base list in the 13th place
and there's ball four so he's stuck with
that curveball he threw it a number of
times
but he couldn't get mercado to bite and
now they're loaded up with two down for
bradley zimmer 0-2
breaking ball ground ball fletcher is
there
my goodness
what an escape had a fast plane down and
in slider would work great
like that edges strikes out detmers has
two quick outs here in the second
brandon marshall for three last night
got him looking beautiful fastball
i mean that was right down ontario
street
third strikeout for mckenzie
down goes the deal
mayfield drives that ball to left center
and deep straw and mercado back and it's
off the wall straw has it
and mayfield pulls in with a two out
double and that's the first hit of the
day
against mckenzie ohtani struck out in
the first first base is open but
mackenzie
has gone after everybody so far
mackenzie again ready the 1-2 is swung
on and missed down and in with a nasty
curveball to strike him out his fifth on
the afternoon a runner stranded in
scoring position
no score middle of the third bottom of
the third top of the order due up for
cleveland mile straw will lead it off
off the end of the bat base hit center
field for
miles strong third hit for the indians
in the month of august rosario batting
355. it's fourth best in the
american league
trying to go the other way and it gets
through miles will hit the bag he'll
make it easily to third base
and the indians have them at the corners
with nobody out
high drive deep left field
it is gone a home run
how's that for setting the table and
cleaning it up oh baby that curveball
stayed up there
and it is not coming back
and there's a ball shot to the alley
and he can't get it
oscar's got at least two and he'll hold
right there with a one-out double
[Applause]
swung out smashed up the middle diving
behind second fletcher up with it throw
to first in the dirt dug out by walls
they got him and so the call is
overturned
mercado has had third
david fletcher
143 cedric mullins 142 that's american
league hit leaders
center field strong piece of cake
that's hit well bradley zimmer on the
dead run makes a sliding catch to retire
this side in order
that hard breakable or split would be
tough
and there's a good break of all there
that's a swing and miles straw strikes
out
yeah that's a four pitch walk to bring
up jose ramirez well joe madden has made
the change
in detmer's exits with ramirez waiting
three-nothing indians andrew wants is in
and wants
will face jose ramirez who's doubled as
a three-run homer
adele
backing up
rosario at first
and andrew wants comes in and finishes
the inning
look at that
just so easy half dozen strikeouts for
dr stixx
as reyes takes strike three call
a welcome addition to this ball game
lance comes in and looks sharp
incredibly he's had a tough time dealing
with that breaker ball down and in with
two strikes he's going to be ready to go
miss he got him again with that breaking
ball down and in seven strikeouts for
tristan mckenzie
10 in a row set down by the right-hander
no doubt
broken bat that's going to drop
four base hit
so owen miller is two for three today
mike myers in right now three nothing
ball game bottom six
there's a base hitter to right field for
big earn
and owen miller stops at second
1-1
there's the ground ball
fletch turn
and straw did not get out of the box at
all
my goodness that's a terrific double
play for the angels to get
fletch gets on top of that and rips it
into left field for a hit
oh buckle him
another wicked curve his eighth
strikeout of the day
seven shutout frames
for sticks mckenzie amid two hits and a
walk today
get hard hit deep
up and out
number seven for a bed rosario he knew
it as soon as he hit it
timing was perfect on getting that put
down
his third hit of the day his 11th
three-hit game
he's off
and the 3-2 topped off the plate gonna
be a tough play barehand grab
the big man beats it out for an infield
single
it was a nice play by mayfield got rid
of it but you can see he gets there and
he beats it out
that's now first and second
still nobody out
another slow chopper
and the pitcher goes down
couldn't come up with it everybody's
safe and they're loaded up
sam selman this is bradley zimmer
infield in
and zimmer slugs it to left
caught by upton tagging as jose ramirez
he will score and it's five nothing
cleveland
[Applause]
and selman
strikes out miller
in that game
everywhere on the first
in time brian shaw
59th appearance on the year
marsh line drive that to the corner and
that should be extra basis iglesias
into third
and the angels have got something going
here in the eighth they've
tapper left side
there's an out there
safe there
the run scores and here comes otani and
i think he's just happy not to see
tristan mckenzie because mckenzie struck
him out three times
weak bouncer to second
whoa wide throw but a nice grab by owen
miller one down
the one-two
swag and a miss hey he struck him out to
end the game
and the indians have dominated the
angels in the first two of this series
[Music]
you